it is July 29 2023 and you're watching
the code report imagine a futuristic
Utopia where you commute to your
dead-end job on a magic levitating hover
train then hop on your hoverboard to
meet up with your friends to make tick
tocks using Android phones that have
nearly unlimited battery power zero heat
production and use quantum chips that
are a billion times faster than your
current phone that future may not be as
far off as you think if we're to believe
the South Korean scientists who recently
claimed to have discovered a room
temperature ambient pressure
superconductor known as LK 99 if it
turns out to be true this would easily
be the greatest scientific discovery of
the 21st century the only caveat though
is that it might be total BS they
recently released two non-peer-reviewed
papers and scientists around the world
are currently racing to reproduce their
results to understand why this is such a
big deal though we need to stop
pretending that we know what a
superconductor is a regular conductor is
just a material that allows electricity
or electrons to flow through it like
aluminum and high voltage transmission
lines or copper wires in your house gold
and silver if you're a baller or even
ionized gas like fluorescent light bulbs
not to mention salt water is a good
conductor the problem is that as
electrons flow through these metals they
meet some resistance and that resistance
causes heat that's why our computers
need fans and heat sinks and why power
lines need to run at very high voltages
it's really not ideal now
superconductors are materials that can
transfer electricity with zero
resistance that sounds awesome but the
problem is that they only work in super
cool temperatures like approaching
absolute zero or under extreme pressure
like Ocean Gate Titan pressure and that
makes them nearly useless for all
practical applications with a few
exceptions like highly specialized MRI
machines they also have interesting
magnetic properties
how do they work type 1 superconductors
expel all magnetic fields when
transitioning to a superconducting state
which is known as the Meisner effect and
we've got type 2 superconductors that
don't completely expel magnetic fields
and can operate at relatively higher
temperatures which makes them more
suitable for practical applications
today but LK 99 if it's even legit would
completely change the superconductor
game because it operates at room
temperature with ambient air pressure
and surprisingly cooking this stuff up
isn't that difficult you just take some
lead oxide and some lead sulfate heat it
at 725 degrees Celsius for 24 hours and
that should give you some lanarkite then
create some copper phosphide with a
vacuum mix them together and heat them
up and now you've got LK 99 it's
surprisingly simple and the next 48
hours will be really interesting to see
if other Cooks can actually get this
recipe to work the Practical use cases
for such a material are impossible to
understate electronics will become
faster and more efficient medical Tech
would become cheaper and more accessible
it could open the door to things like
Quantum Computing and frictionless
transportation and dramatically improve
Energy Efficiency to the point where
politicians don't need to feed us bugs
to make the weather better now before
you get too excited and start investing
all your money on levitating train
stocks many smart people out there are
highly skeptical of this paper by
comparison the highest temperature
superconductors of today operate at
negative 20 degrees Celsius and require
pressures of 25 million PSI and there's
already a rabbit hole of drama
surrounding the paper like it looks like
it may have been uploaded without
everyone being on board which might
suggest some infighting between
researchers and just recently another
scientist had his paper taken down that
had also claimed to discover a room
temperature superconductor I mean I get
it everyone wants to be the next Alfred
Einstein and in rare cases people might
cherry pick data or outright lie to get
that cloud however I'm keeping my
fingers crossed for LK 99 because I
promise my kids a hoverboard for
Christmas and I really can't let them
down again this has been the code report
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one